bevor wir gleich darüber sprechen
werfen wir einmal einen Blick rein in
das was da geschehen ist im November ein
paar wenige Bilder aber die haben es
tatsächlich in sich Potzdam 25 November
2023 ein Geheimtreffen im Landhaus Adlon
anwesend sind hochrangige
afdptiker
Neonazis Unternehmer und auch CDU
Mitglieder aus der konservativen
werteunion das Thema der Versammlung die
massenhafte Abschiebung von Menschen mit
Zuwanderungsgeschichte das
recherchenetzwerk Korrektiv kann
undercover einen Reporter einschleusen
der die Konferenz mit einer SmartWatch
mitfilmt den Hauptvortrag hält einer der
bekanntesten Köpfe der rechtsextremen
identitären Martin selner stellt einen
Masterplan zur Remigration vor wie es
der Veranstalter nennt selner zäht laut
Korrektiv drei Zielgruppen auf die
Deutschland verlassen sollen
Asylbewerber ausl mit Bleiberecht und so
wörtlich nicht assimilierte Staatsbürger
sprich auch Menschen mit deutschem Pass
laut Korrektiv gibt es keine Einwände
gegen diese Pläne auch nicht von den AFD
Vertretern unter ihnen ein durchaus
bekanntes Gesicht Roland Hartwig der
inzwischen entlassene Referent von
Parteichefin Alis
Weidel inzwischen ist bekannt dass das
potzdammer Treffen nicht das erste
dieser Art war und vermutlich auch nicht
das
letzte ja Herr wiinson wie erfährt man
von einer solchen
Geschichte ja das Interessante ist ähm
der Organisator für diese Veranstaltung
war ähm ein ehemaliger Zahnarzt aus
Düsseldorf gern und möing der schon seit
70er 80er 90er Jahre aktiv in der
rechtsextremen Szene unterwegs ist und
ähm der sich dann als Düsseldorfer Forum
vorstellt und der hatte eingeladen hat
also in einem Brief äh Leute eingeladen
von denen er hoffte Geld zu bekommen ja
die Idee war eine Veranstaltung zu
machen Deutschland steht vor dem
Untergang aber jetzt könnne man
sozusagen vielleicht auch noch retten
Zahnarzt ja aus Düsseldorf ein eher
Zahnarzt ja das der kümmert sich nicht
nur um das braune im Zahnschmelz ja das
vielleicht auch das auch schwarz dann
manchmal aber äh er hat sich immer
sozusagen dieser rechtsextremen Szene es
gibt also Bücher
aus den 80er Jahren wo er da schon vor
der Überfremdung warend da war die
Merkel noch in der DDR unterwegs ja da
gab es
also diesen flüchtlingszuzug gar nicht
ja das ist so die Idee die dahinter
steht ein
monoethischer Staat die im Grunde
genommen die Prozesse die in der
Bundesrepublik seit den 60er Jahren
passiert sind die zurückzudringen und
die hat er schon damals ein
monoethnischer ST monnischer
St er Staat wo im Grunde genommen
jegliche andere Menschen die aus anderen
Ländern hingekommen sind und H heimisch
geworden sind keinen Platz haben sollen
so und dann gibt's noch eine
zweite zweiten Namen der interessant ist
Herr Limmer ja das H Christian Limmer
der wer ist also hans-Christian Limmer
standand eben auch auf der
unterschrieben neben möhing hat eben
auch ein hans-Christian Limmer
unterschrieben und der ist also bekannt
in der Nahrungsmittelbranche ja der
hatte backwer
gegründet gesellschaftter von
hansem Glück und potsalat und das ist
insofern hat uns natürlich elektrisiert
weil das im Grund der dritte Millionär
aus der Lebensmittelbranche ist der mit
den Rechten kokettiert da war der fing
da war der Müller und jetzt eben der
Limmer und der unterschrieb halt dieser
Einladung und der war aber nicht da und
als wir ihn konfrontiert hatten hat er
sich von allem distanziert was auf
dieser Veranstaltung besprochen wurde
hat aber die Frage nicht beantwortet wie
seine Unterschrift und sein Name unter
dieser Einladung kommt das hat er sich
dazu nicht geäußert
und gibt's dann ein Hintergrund also ein
einen familiären Hintergrund oder also
man sagt danach kam es dann raus dass er
schon in der rechten Szene
auch unter der Wahrnehmungsgrenze aktiv
wohl ist ja und offenbar auch Herrn Ming
kennt und hat sich dann überreden lassen
mit einzuladen aber war aber nicht auf
dieser Veranstaltung aber das war für
uns natürlich elektrisieren so ein Brief
zu erhalten mit Ort dieser Villa und
Datum und da haben wir dann gesagt so
das müssen wir uns genauer angucken
interessantes Gebäude ne da kennt man
auch ne ja das kennt man also Babylon
Berlin hat sich ja da als Drehort
gesucht und da haben wir gesagt so da
müssen wir mehr Informationen zu
bekommen mhm und äh dann ist es uns
gelungen äh ein Reporter von von uns an
dem Tag einzuschleußen weil das ja ein
Hotel ist ist imm gelungen da zu buchen
und dann war er sozusagen da als die
ganzen Leute eintrafen und was eben hoch
spannend war wir hatten dann auch noch
ein zweites Schreiben bekommen wo dann
auch präzisiert wurde was da überhaupt
besprochen werden sollte da sollte ein
Masterplan benannt werden Markus selner
sie sagten eben schon Chef der
identitären und der hat gerade sein Buch
herausgegeben
und da steht da genau Österreicher ne in
Österreicher ja ein Österreicher der im
Grunde genommen gerade in dieser rechten
Bewegung einer der führenden Ideologen
ist im Grunde genommen ist das ein
rechter Medienprofi ja ein Werbeprofi
der mit Worten und mit Kampagnen Inhalte
vorantreibt und da sehr sehr
professionell ist und der sollte seinen
Masterplan vorstellen und dies Buch
ist zu lesen und da steht schon drin was
das zentrale ist nämlich die die
Migration das ist sein putzbegriff für
Vertreibung von Menschen aus diesem Land
und da nennt er schon dass der
Staatsbürger drunterfallen sogenannte
nicht assimilierte und damit gibt man
ihm ja die Interpretation zuoheit wer in
diesem Land leben darf und wer nicht und
der hat den Masterplan vorzustellen und
da war der Punkt so wer kommt noch und
dann kam dann führende AFD Leute unter
anderem Gerit die sitzt im Bundestag
dann Roland Hartwig Siegmund
Ulrich Siegmund Fraktionsvorsitzender
von SachsenAnhalt und eben der Hartwig
und der Hartwig ist eine spannende Figur
der war mal im Bundestag vorher Manager
bei Meer und der ist jetzt sozusagen die
rechte Hand von der Weidel
und es gibt ja das hat ihre Sendung
wurde ja mal gesagt dass es so in der
AFD kolpartiert wird dass sie nicht
besonders fleißig seid die Frau Weidel
und er macht sozusagen die gesamte
Arbeit und wird von der
Bundestagsfraktion auch so genannt als
der inoffizielle general sekretär also
eine ganz hohe Figur hat sie gemacht ne
mittlerweile hat sie sich ja nach einer
Woche von ihm
getrennt aber der war eben da und das
Spannende ist er ist eben auch als hat
sich auch vorgestellt ich bin hier
als Mitarbeiter von der Frau Weidel und
hat immer wieder für den Vorstand
gesprochen und dann wurd das Projekt und
da ist der Möring sehr schnell in die
Vollen gegangen und hat gesagt hier wir
Rechte streiten um Corona um Russland um
Israel alles unwichtig Remigration ist
das zentrale Thema und da hat er das
Gesetzt ja Remigration also wir
übernehmen sozusagen an an dem Punkt
diese diese feine Umschreibung dieser
Leute ne eigentlich reden wir das ist
das vornehme Wort für Deportation er hat
das Wort gesagt ist erstmal Vertreibung
ja weil die gehen ja erstmal drauf an
die wollen eine und so wurde das dann
formuliert weil der sag ja vertreiben
wen kann man alles vertreiben und sagt
ja Staatsbürger kann man nicht
vertreiben und da ist dann Herr selner
sehr klar gekommen sag gibt drei Gruppen
das sind die Flüchtlinge sofort raus die
mit aufenhaltsstatus kann man ja
einziehen ja und die Staatsbürger ja
dann macht man eben das ein
jahrzehnteprjekt über maßgeschneiderte
Gesetze über Anpassungsdruck erzeugt man
so eine Druck auf diese Menschen dass
sie eben dann freiwillig gehen und man
hat auch ein Zielort genannt man könnte
ja musterstat in Nordafrika
welchen einfach ein musterstaat als in
Nordafrika formuliert
und es ging auch um Millionen sagt immer
machen sich keine Sorgen um die Logistik
die sind hingekommen die können auch
wieder raus also das wurde beschrieben
und das war das zentrale Ziel und da hat
der möing als das dann so diskutiert
wird auch noch gleich die Idee gebracht
so eine Expertenkommission zu gründen
die eben diesen Prozess der Vertreibung
ich will jetzt diesen Begriff nicht von
den übernehmen den blank
geputzten nach ethischen rechtlichen und
logistischen Gesichtspunkt ten
vorzubereiten dass wenn dann eine rechte
Partei an die Macht kommt schon was in
der Schublade liegt und hat dann auch
gleich in den Herrn Maßen vorgeschlagen
der war nicht da und die als ich den
Maßen dazu konfrontiert hat hat er
gesagt D will nichts zu tun haben aber
hat ih dann vorgeschlagen in dieser
Kommission auch mitzuarbeiten also die
sind da sehr konkret und das war halt so
der Masterplan und alles andere diente
dann dazu wie man diesen Masterplan
umsetzen kann ja also der Martin der
sagt immer es kommt gar nicht so auf die
politische Partei an ob die siegt oder
nicht ich brauche eine gesellschaftliche
Zustimmung ja das sind ja so diese
vorfeldsache und der hat sich das ein
bisschen von dem gramski abgeguckt ja
der sagt also die
graswurzelpolitik man muss sozusagen
eine Idee in der Gesellschaft in
Universitäten unter Eliten wachsen
lassen und eines der großen Spielfelder
zur Zeit der Politik sind die sozialen
Medien und da ist ja auch die AFD
besonders gut und da sagt der SEL das
muss man halt weiter unterstützen und so
ein Programm hat dann gernard möing hat
dann Hartwig vorgestellt Programm
von dem Sohn des möingen mit influenzern
eben diese Idee durchzusetzen Frau W
frag offen auch an Robin Alexander
überrascht sie das wenn sie sowas hören
also ich find es nicht wirklich
überraschend weil ich meine dass die AFD
eine Partei ist in der Nazis sind und
man sich auch mit Nazis trifft ist jetzt
nicht ganz neu also dieser selner der
hat ja ein Buch geschrieben also das was
sie was er dort offensichtlich referiert
hat hat er ja vorher in ein Buch
dargelegt also diese ganze das ist
Nazi-Ideologie das ist richtig düstere
faschistoide
Ideologie und natürlich wenn man sich
mit solchen Leuten hinsetzt weiß man was
man tut wobei ich sagen muss die sind ja
sehr umtriebig also dieser mörik z.B ich
habe das ja vorher in der Presse gelesen
dass der also rechtsradikale
Vergangenheit hat der die ich kenne den
der hat auch versucht mit mir Kontakt
aufzunehmen der hat mir mehrfach Mails
geschrieben eben also das heißt die
versuchen offenbar in alle Richtungen
ich wusste nur vorher nicht dass das ein
Rechtsradikaler ist also hab sie darauf
reagiert der hat mir nette Mails
geschrieben der hat mir vor Jahren mal
ein Abendessen mit einem linken
deutschen kapartisten vermittelt also
das heißt ich war überhaupt nicht
bösgläubig dass der aus der rechten
Szene kommt also wollen sie sagen
welcher
linke das wäre jetzt also jemand vor dem
ich größten Respekt habe den ich aber
jetzt hier nicht nennen will weil der
jetzt sonst auch gleich irgendwie in in
die Schublade kommt damit nur sagen
diese Leute sind offenbar sehr umtriebig
in dem Versuch irgendwie an alle
Richtungen Kontakte zu knüpfen ich meine
jetzt werde ich mit diesem Mann
keinerlei Kontakte mehr haben aber wenn
jemand sich so einführt wenn jemand auf
so eine Art Kontakt aufnimmt dann
erreicht er natürlich dass man überhaupt
nicht drüber nachdenkt dass das ein
rechter ist bei dem selner ist es was
anderes der ist ein bekannter rechter
und wenn man sich mit dem hinsetzt ist
völlig klar dass man dort also wirklich
ja sich sich absolut in ein
sikale e und deswegen was ich nur
erstaunlich finde in der ganzen Debatte
dass man das mit so einem
Überraschungsmoment diskutiert weil ich
meine Herr höcke ist in etwa so drauf
wie Herr selner und der ist Mitglied
nicht nur der AFD sondern
Fraktionsvorsitzender in Thüringen also
das heißt sie haben ja diese Leute in
ihren Reihen das ist ja nicht neu und
deswegen kann man und sollte man sich
immer wieder darüber empören aber was
mich viel mehr umtreibt ist wie schaffen
wir es dass nicht so viele Menschen in
Deutschland so verzweifelt sind so
politisch heimatlos dass sie am Ende so
eine Partei trotz der höckes und trotz
der Nazis wählen Sie wählen Sie ja nicht
wegen denen sie wählen Sie trotz dieser
und das hat etwas mit der
Regierungspolitik zu tun und deswegen
glaube ich diese Debatte ist wichtig die
sie angestoßen haben um einfach noch mal
quasi ins Schaufenster zu stellen was
das für eine Partei ist aber am Ende die
wichtigere Frage ist
oder bzw für mich die wichtigere Frage
wie erreichen wir dass diese Menschen
eine seriöse politische Adresse haben
und nicht mehr aus Protest eben diese
AFD wählen der tatsächlich sich solche
Leute da auch eine im Kopf
zufälligerweise darüber reden wir gleich
aber ich habe das Gefühl die wichtige
Frage die die beiden Herren hier im Kopf
haben ist noch mal eine andere gerade
Herr bzmann sie häen no bei dem linken
Kabarettisten oder ich möchte gern zwei
Fragen setzen was ich ganz spannend
finde weil das bestätigt dann unsere
Quellen weil mörigen pralte auch damit
Ihre Telefonnummer zu haben also ich
glaube meine Telefonnummer hat er nicht
aber meine
Mail der pralte auf der Veranstaltung
die Telefonnummer von ihnen zu haben
Frau Bank nicht und da würde ich jetzt
fragen wie ist denn das gegangen haben
sie mal mit ihm telefoniert oder haben
sie nur Mails ausgus ja und er hat mir
da habe ich das war glaub
2014 dieses Abendessen vermittelt also
da da war er war was heiß was heißt
vermittelt Frau Wagenknecht mal fragen
was heißt das na er hat mir gesagt dass
er den kennt ich habe großen Respekt vor
dem Mann und da hat gesagt wollen wir
wollen wir d man kennenlernen und dann
habe ich gesagt ja sehr gerne würde mich
sehr freuen und dann haben wir da
zusammen Abend gegessen ja das ist der
vollkerpiss ja
das ja gut ich wollte jetzt nicht
jemanden der jetzt sich nicht Wehen kann
aber ja aber es ist ja auch nicht aber
ich meine er ist ja wirklich ein
ehrenwerter Mann der nichts mit
irgendwelchen rechtsradikalen zu tun hat
woll ich ih jetzt nicht nam er hat das
vermittelt aber ja und sie warum was ist
die Motivation das würde ich gerne mal
verstehen also wenn mir jemand anbietet
dass ich ein Menschen treffen kann den
ich interessant finde den ich
hochrespektable finde dann freut mich
das und dann mache ich das hat ja auch
stattgefunden also es war ja war ja kein
Fake darf fragen wann der das gemacht
hat ich glaube es war so
2014 2013 sowas also 10 Jahre her aber
was hatte der zimarzt davon was hatte
mörik davon
na ja den Kontakt zu mir also er hatte
bei mir einen sehr guten Leumund dadurch
ist doch logisch darf ich mal wieso ruft
der Kabarettist nicht selber an der hat
per Mail wir haben per Mail wir haben
hatten per ma aber wieso braucht ein
Linker gabartist
ein rechten erleben sie sowas nicht dass
Leute sagen ich kenne jemanden wollen
sie den mal treffen sowas ist doch oft
und dann wenn also ich meine ich werde
öfter gefragt ob ich Leute treffe sind
es Leute die ich nicht treffen will dann
sage ich nö habe ich kein Interesse und
manchmal sind es Leute wo ich es
interessant finde und dann sage ich
natürlich ja ich habe
Interesse und wie gesagt da das jetzt
ein Kontakt war wo ich jetzt nicht im
Traum auf rechtsradikale Hintergründe
schließen
konnte und danach hat er mir immer mal
Mails geschickt dadurch kannte ich
diesen Namen als er jetzt in der Presse
war und und woher hatte der Ihre
Telefonnummer er hatte nicht meine
Telefonnummer er hat mich über meine
meine e-mailadress er behauptet das ja
also ich habe ja nicht sein Telefon
geguckt also er behauptet das sagen
unsere Quellen äh pralt er damit ja dass
er also gut vernetzt also ich glaube
meine Nummer hat er nicht aber er hat
auf jeden Fall meine E-Mailadresse und
sie haben sich all die Jahre Mails hin
und her geschrieben er hat sich danach
immer mal wieder gemeldet so auf der
Ebene auch sie haben ja gerade in der
Talk Show eine gute Figur gemacht oder
Sie haben eine schöne Rede im Bundestag
gehalten und sie haben auch geschrieben
und dann habe ich mich bedankt und das
war wann zuletzt letzter Auftritt bei
uns
oder ich das kann ich ih nicht sagen ich
weiß nur dass ich jetzt der Name war ja
in der Press oder vor Monaten oder vor
Jahren nein also es ist auf jeden Fall
schon Monate vielleicht Jahre her also
Monate mindestens aber eher Jahre aber
der Name war jetzt in der Presse und
dann ist mir das aufgefallen da stand ja
auch dass der schon lange in
rechtsradikalen Bezügen ist und dann
habe ich erstmal geschluckt und dachte
ja was der Mann und scheint aber
wirklich der zu sein also noch mal eine
Frage dazu ich äh will ihnen wirklich in
keinsterweise irgendwas unterstellen
wirklich nicht aber was ich nicht
verstehe ist wir leben in Zeiten des
Internets ich erlebe das auch wenn wenn
mich jemand anruft kontaktiert das das
kann ich nachvollziehen das erste was
ich mache wenn ich jemanden nicht kenne
ich schaue erstmal wer ist das ja gut
das G damals er hat sich auf einen
gemeinsamen Bekannten berufen der damals
ja das sind eben wie gesagt wir reden
über die Jahre 13 2013 2014 ich hatte
damals Kontakt zu Max Otte der war
damals ein Bestseller Autor ein
starautor
auch hier und darüber ist das gekommen
sehr komisch abgebogen irgendwann okay
ja aber das war da so und er war ein
Bekannter von ihm das war sozusagen der
bezugh und so haben wir uns dann also
hat er dann auch meine Mailadresse
gehabt so haben wir dann eben dieses
Gespräch damals dieses Abendessen
gemacht und ich will das ja nur als
Beispiel anführen wie Leute aus der
Szene offensichtlich versuchen auch in
Bereiche Kontakte zu knüpfen die mit
solchen Geschichten wirklich überhaupt
nichts zu tun haben und sich aber sogar
eine Legende aufbauen die dann einen ja
wirklich gutglauubig macht das ist ja
einfach die Vorgeschichte die ich
erzählen wollte hat mal nach ihrer neuen
Partei gefragt und ob er da unterstützen
kann oder war das in irgendeiner Form
Thema in ihren E-Mails nein also über
meine also also er hat sich wenn ich
mich jetzt richtig erinnere bestimmt
unser letzter Kontakt weiß ich nicht ein
Jahr zwei also nicht seitdem irgendwie
die Partei gegründet wurde meines
Wissens hat er auch keinen
Mitgliedsantrag gestellt aber wir haben
inzwischen so viele mit diese Anträge
dass ich die nicht alle gecheckt habe
aber zumindest nicht über mich
persönlich da da noch mal fragen Frau
sie sie sind eine sehr akribische
Arbeiterin sie sind jemand der
recherchiert sie kommen aus dem
Journalismus ich lobe oft ihre Stücke
ich lese die auch ganz häufig lese Ihre
Kolumnen und so weiter ich ich weiß
sozusagen ihre journalistischen
Qualitäten um es mal Soz sagen und hier
sitzen zwar andere Hochkaräter und mir
fällt es so schwer das zu verstehen also
das schreibt ihnen niemand ich verstehe
den ersten Kontakt okay auch noch meine
wegen den zweiten aber das schreibt
ihnen jemand wie dieser Mann über 10
Jahre hinweg und sie interessieren sich
nie recherchieren nie so wirklich wer
das eigentlich ist wissen sie wie viele
Leute mir länger als 10 Jahre schreiben
also ich habe ein ganzen Tross von
Leuten sie hab keine Ahnung wer das ist
doch die mir immer mal schreiben also
sag mal auf der Ebene schreiben sie
waren da gerade gut oder sie meinetwegen
auch sie waren da mal gerade nicht so
gut also die mir einfach Mails schreiben
ich habe ein Mailpostfach da kommen am
Tag zwei 100 Mails an und den viele
Namen merke ich mir auch nicht also es
gibt da auch z Namen die da wenn Sie
mich fragen würden haben sie mal den
gekannt dann werde ich ihn sagen Nein
und in Wirklichkeit ist das einer bei
möing habe ich es mir eigentlich nur
gemerkt weil jetzt damals ja diesen
interessanten Kontakt gab und weil er
dann immer wieder sich mal gemeldet hat
nur deswegen habe ich mir den Namen
gemerkt also es gibt viele Leute die mir
wirklich auch häufig schreiben sehr nett
schreiben viele ehrliche Leute auch die
einfach wahrnehmen was ich mache haben
sichems mit troffen mal persönlich na
bei diesem Abendessen mit Möring da war
der auch dabei ja ja sicher er hat das
ja vermittelt okay nee ich hatte das so
verstanden sie haben sich mit dem
Kabarettisten getroffen ich hatte nicht
verstanden ne nein er war dabei und
okayi ihm zu Hause bitte bei ihm war es
bei ihm zu Hause oder war nein nein in
dem
Restaurant und wenn man sich dann mit so
einem Mann trifft an so eineem Abend man
man trinkt dann das eine oder andere
Tässchen Rotwein und so weiter
irgendwann versteht man doch wer einem
da gesinnungsmäßig gegenüber sitzt oder
nicht also was mich an dem Abend
interessiert hat war Volker pistbas weil
ich seine Arbeit sehr gut finde sein
Kabarett sehr gut fand und weil mich
interessiert hat den Mann kennenzulernen
und ehrlich gesagt Herr Möring hat mich
gar ich hätte ihn noch nicht mal optisch
erkannt also ich kann ihn jetzt wenn ich
das Gesicht sehe nicht sagen ob der das
war aber er war es natürlich weil er hat
es ja
vermittelttimt kann es nicht auch sein
dass äh Herr möhing in ihn auch eine Art
äh hoffnungsfigur sieht für seinen Plan
also dass er sie nicht also ehrlich
gesagt jetzt kommen sie mir aber
wirklich auf einem Niveau also tut mir
leid also mit solchen Plänen wie sie sie
ja gerade geschildert haben also ich
weiß nicht ob Herr mörik die so vertritt
aber ich gehe mal davon aus wenn er mit
Herr selner und ähnlichen Dingen zu tun
hat also mit sowas habe ich nichts zu
tun und mit sowas will ich nichts zu tun
haben und ich glaube wer immer meine
öffentliche Arbeit verfolgt der weiß
dass ich sowas zutiefst unappetitlich
finde dass ich dagegen Politik mache
dass sowas sich jemals in
Deutschland nicht unterstellt aber
die Anmerkung ist ja insofern richtig
börn höcke hat sie doch auch eingeladen
in die AFD zu kommen ne habe ich das
falsch im Kopf doch also wissen Sie sie
wissen doch genau wie das läuft ja ja
wenn wir höcke sowas sagt ist er in der
gesamten Medienwelt überall wird er
zitiert ist ja auch wenn man eine
Kundgebung macht und irgendein
rechtsradikaler geht dahin kommt der in
alle Medien selbstverständlich doch die
Einladung für die Rechtsradikalen
dahinzugehen ich halte diese öffentliche
Debatte über alle Maßen für dumm weil
wir damit die den rechten vor allen den
Rechtsradikalen also hier reden wir ja
wirklich über Nazis hier reden wir ja
nicht über Leute die es ja in der AFD
auch gibt die eher konservativ sind aber
jetzt nicht irgendwie Rechtsextremisten
sonder hier reden wir über Extremisten
wenn wir denen immer was ist Frau Weidel
für Sie Frau Weidel ist jemand der also
ich meine die kommt aus der High
Gesellschaft die ist in in hohem Grade
politisch würde ich sagen na bei der FDP
und bei der CDU bestimmt nicht bei mir
aber ich halte es auch da um das
deutlich zu sagen für falsch wenn man
jetzt Frau Weidel zu einem Nazi erklärt
das ist eine eine überzogene hysterische
Debatte die am Ende der AFD hilft wenn
wenn Frau Weidel ein Nazi ist dann frage
ich mich was ist dann Herr höcke also
wir verschieben dadurch die Maßstäbe ich
frag nur weil mir das aufgefallen ist
und deswegen ist es ganz interessant
dass wir diese diese diese dieses
Gespräch jetzt gerade haben ähm dass sie
in den letzten Tagen haben sie sehr
auffällig Partei für Frau Weidel
ergriffen nein ich ich verreif nicht ich
ergreif genau mit dem Argument also nein
sondern ich ich finde dass auch sie als
Journalist und die Medien doch mal
verstehen müssen dass die Art und Weise
wie hier im Land mit der AFD umgegangen
wird dazu geführt hat dass sie jetzt bei
22 oder 23% steht weil es keine
sachliche Auseinandersetzung ist
sachlich Auseinandersetzung sich salich
hei sachlich heißt dass jemand wie Herrn
höcke der wirklich sa Propaganda
betreibt der der Hitlers reden kopiert
in der Struktur dass ich den auch ein
Faschisten oder ein Nazi nenne aber
Sachlichkeit heißt eben auch dass ich
nicht so tue als ob Frau Weidel genau
das gleiche vertritt weil such ja Nähe
sie sucht Nähe zum Herrn kubitek sie hat
den Herrn Hartwig sie ist immerhin ja
auch Vorsitzender einer Partei in der es
die höckes gibt also ich will doch nicht
hier jetzt Partei greifen ich wünsche
mir nur dass wir eine glaubwürdige
Auseinandersetzung machen und nicht eine
überzogene weil diese Art das ist doch
die Leute nehmen manches wahr und zwar
zurecht als Kampagne wenn sie etwas als
Kampagne wahrnehmen dann hilft das dem
Opfer der Kampagne also sie können das
auch am Beispiel Hubert eiwanger sehen
also Hubert eiwanger hat jetzt eine
Statur bundesweit und auch eine
Popularität die etwas damit zu tun hat
oder bzw mit dem Anlass zu tun hat äh
der auf eine Kampagne zurückgeht also er
hat in seiner Schulzeit ein sehr
unappetitliches Flugblatt geschrieben
oder wurde zumindest damit in Verbindung
gebracht das was da drin stand hat in
Deutschland keine Sympathie niemand wird
das gut finden dass die Art und Weise
der Auseinandersetzung aber nicht ums
Flugblatt ging sondern um jemanden
mundtot zu machen der auf einer
Kundgebung gesprochen hatte hat am Ende
dazu geführt dass plötzlicher eiwangeer
sehr populär geworden ist und ich will
ja nur drauf hinweisen dass das eine Art
und Weise ist wie wir der AFD helfen und
deswegen finde ich wichtiger z.B auch
sich mal anzugucken was vertritt die AFD
eigentlich wirtschaftspolitisch
sozialpolitisch was würde das bedeuten
wenn das AFD prramm umgesetzt wird die
AFD ist ja nicht für eine gerechte
Leistungsgesellschaft die AFD will kein
höheren mindestloh auch keine
Subventionen für Landwirte ja auch das
nicht sie will auch keine höhere
gesetzliche Rente sie will auch nicht
dass mieten reguliert werden sie will
nicht dass Krankenhäuser vom
Renditedruck befreit werden also ich
finde man kann sich auch mal inhaltlich
auseinandersetzen und das finde ich
sinnvoller als die Art und Weise wie wir
das jetzt deswegen inhaltlich noch mal
auseinandergesetzt Alis Weidel wenn Alis
Weidel sozusagen die tonangebende Figur
in der AFD wäre wir spielen jetzt ein
Moment in Gedanken einmal durch börn
höcke gäbe es da nicht wäre dann jemand
wie Alice Weidel für Sie mit Ihrer neuen
Partei Koalitionspartner na ich habe ja
gerade gesagt inhaltlich
sozialpolitisch sind wir s weit
auseinander wie man auseinander sein
kann also Alis Weidel könnte sicherlich
mit der FDP koalieren wenn eso sie sehr
nah beieinander sind ja
aber
Migrationspolitik also bei Migration
haben wir gerade gesehen dass das in der
AFD ein weites Feld ist also wenn die
AFD reigration will sind wir nicht
beineinander dass man die
migrationszahlen reduzieren muss dass
die Zahlen viel zu hoch sind dass das
unsere Kommunen unsere Städte und
Gemeinden überfordert ja das sieht doch
inzwischen jeder da ist es ja dieum dass
man dass der AFD überlässt statt endlich
in dem Bereich etwas zu tun die die
Menschen spüren doch dass es so nicht
weitergeht dass wir tatsächlich auch in
bestimmten Ansätzen islamistisch
geprägte Parallelgesellschaften haben da
da ist es identitätsstiftend sich im
Grunde gegen die hiesige Kultur gegen
die hiesige Lebensweise zu positionieren
das ist doch ein Problem und wir haben
auch die soziale Überforderung wir haben
die Schulklassen wo dann über 50% kein
Deutsch sprechen also das sind ja re
und über Jahre hat man das
weggeschwiegen hat es der AFD überlassen
das anzusprechen und natürlich ist sie
dadurch immer stärker geworden Robin
Alexander als jemand der die politische
Landschaft kennt wie wenige andere hat
Frau wknechten Punkt wenn sie sagt da
wird zu hysterisch gesprochen gibt von
ihnen den Satz das war jetzt nicht die
Wannseekonferenz die da stattgefunden
hat in Berlin so ein bisschen flap sich
dahin gesagt und ohne das relativieren
zu meinen aber erklären Sie einmal was
sie mit dem Gedanken meinen also was
Korrektiv gemacht hat war ja eine
Recherche und das ist eine Recherche zu
der ich in der Substanz gratuliere so
und diese äh Recherche hat eine enorme
wirkungentfaltet die ist auch inszeniert
worden das kritisiere ich ausdrücklich
nicht weil klappern gehört zum Handwerk
und äh ich habe es auch schon mal so
ähnig gemacht so nur das Problem ist
natürlich SMer mit ihrem Buch mit hier
von der Welt verkaufen unsere Recherchen
und gucken dass wir die unter die Leute
kriegen nur das Ding ist natürlich man
macht diese Leute auch dadurch bekannt
also ein Beispiel der Begriff
Remigration ist Unwort des Jahres wie
kann etwas Unwort des Jahres sein was
80% der Bevölkerung noch nie gehört
hatten also wir nehmen die Terminologie
dieser Leute und verbreiten sie oder
dieser Herr selner über den wir jetzt
gesprochen haben das ist jemand der im
gesellschaftlichen abseits sein Leben
gefristet hat und es wäre auch gut wenn
er da geblieben wäre ja und diese
Theorie die die selber haben nach
gramschi kulturelle Hegemonie da sind
die natürlich Lichtjahre von entfernt
aber natürlich trinken die heute Abend
eine Flasche Krimsekt dass wir so über
die gesprochen haben das ist doch klar
so und darauf so das heißt nicht dass
man das nicht berichten soll also ich
wie gesagt ich gratuliere Korrektiv zu
der Recherche nur ich würde schon gucken
immer auch einordnen immer sagen das ist
der rechte Rand das bleibt auch der
rechte Rand mit Betonung auf Rand me ja
das ist nicht so dass das
auch es ist nicht so weil dort jetzt
Unternehmer dabei waren dass die Elite
dieses Landes so denkt oder oder die
Wirtschaft das ist nicht so wenn es jem
und auch noch nicht mal die AFD
ne muss auch gar nicht man kann das und
und da würde ich schon auch
also ich bin insofern bei Frau
Wagenknecht dass man den wirklich ein
Gefallen tut wenn man eine
migrationsskepsis oder eine
migrationskritik die man ja gar nicht
teilen muss verwechselt mit dem was
selner will nämlich Leute ethnisch
sortieren das ist etwas anderes und da
kann man einfach nur zur Differenzierung
raten wo ich Ihnen widersprechen müsste
wenn ich darf diese Geschichte man hätte
Kritik an Migrationspolitik der AFD
überlassen stimmt einfach nicht es ist
in Mainstream Medien kritisch über
Merkels Öffnung nein ich habe das 2015
2016 getan ich s
hier Seehofer hat das getan als CSU Chef
also es ist einfach nicht wahr dass sie
oder Herr höcke kommen mussten und sagen
unsere Migrationspolitik läuft nicht gut
das stimm ich das sind alles Fragen die
eigentlich aus der gesellschaftlichen
Mitte beantwortet werden können und in
anderen Ländern ja auch werden und da
ist ein Problem dass diese Antwort
gerade noch nicht so gekommen ist dass
es alle Leute erreicht hat oder die
Mehrheit der Leute sie erinnern sich ne
wir haben damals also medial auch rede
jetzt mal selbstkritisch über unsere
eigene Branche ist ja nicht unsere
Kernkompetenz Selbstkritik aber wir
beide haben uns damals ausgetauscht ich
ich habe Auszüge aus ihrem Buch gelesen
als das rauskam damals die getriebenen
und sagte lass uns bitte sehr zügig
Robin Alexander einladen weil ich das
sehr interessant fand wie sie das
recherchiert haben und dann haben wir
uns hier sehr lange drüber unterhalten
und dann gab es eine zweite Einladung
das kan auch alles überprüfen hab uns
ein weiteres Mal sehr intensiv darüber
auseinandergesetzt und so entstand
sozusagen auch eine eine eine
Bekanntschaft die wir seitdem auch ein
bisschen pflegen und ich schätze sie
auch sehr aber sie zur Wahrheit gehört
auch wir waren damals am Beginn und da
hat sie einen Punkt durchaus auch ein
bisschen einsamere Rufer in der Wüste ja
also was also wenn Sie etwas berichten
was vielleicht auch noch in Teilen neu
ist dann gibt's auch jemand der sagt das
sollte besser nicht gesagt werden oder
das nutzt den falschen oder so weiter
aber das muss man doch aushalten als
Figur des öffentlichen Lebens also oder
als Journalist ich kann do nicht ich
kann do nicht nicht ausgehalten ja aber
ich kann doch nicht gleichzeitig bei
Markus Land sitzen und behaupten meine
Meinung wird unterdrückt es kann nur
eins von beiden stim es kommt doch drauf
an wie das debattenklima ist und ich ich
meine ich halte es auch aus wenn man mir
alles mögliche unterstellt nur ich weiß
dass ich damals das fing ja schon 2015
2016 an mir wurde immer erzählt na immer
unterstellt ich sei AFD nah und zwar
deshalb od also am Anfang ging es ja vor
allem um dieses Thema weil ich gesagt
habe diese unkontrollierte Migration ist
ein Problem und das wird sich auch immer
mehr eskalieren und das wurde immer dann
in diese Ecke gestellt also man wurde
immer in eine rechte Ecke gestellt und
das zeigt doch dass die Leute natürlich
den wird ja nahe gelegt die rechte Ecke
das sind die Kritiker also ist rechts
gut also die rechte Ecke ist ist dann
irgendwie eigentlich ganz heimlich und
dann kommt eine Partei die genau dort
steht und dann wird sie eben stärker
also es gab schon einen starken Druck
also ich will doch nicht sagen dass
niemand das kritisiert hat aber in der
Politik ein extrem starken Druck
Willkommenskultur das war sozusagen die
Mitte das war der Mainstream und wer das
kritisierte der war schon sofort wieder
in dem Verdacht also eigentlich eher
rechtsböse und zumindest außerhalb des
doch des Guten meinungsspektrums also W
war schon in der ziemlichen Ecke das ich
also ich möchte hier vielleicht einen
Punkt noch mal gerne machen es wird so
gesagt das ist ja nur so
Rand im rechten Rand denkt man über die
Vertreibung auch von Staatsbürgern
zurück ich finde das zeigt ja diese
Veranstaltung dass es halt den rechten
Rand verlassen hat und
Vertreter der AFD mit selbsternannt Link
in den AFD Vorstand und direkt z vor
Weidel ist die gesagt haben das wollen
wir und die haben einen
Spitzenkandidaten für die Europawahl
Herr Maximilian Krah der ebenfalls in
einem Buch schreibt dass im Grunde
genommen müsste man 25 Millionen Leute
das für wünschenswert wenn Sie dieses
Land verließen und beklagt dass die
rechtlichen und politischen
Möglichkeiten dazu nicht ausreichen das
ist der Maximilian Krah das heißt die
nutzen diese Empörung dafür um ein ganz
anderes Ziel zu erreichen den geht es
gar nicht darum dass man über die jetzt
ankommenden Flüchtlinge eine logistische
Lösung findet wie und wann die deren
aufenalsstatum bestimmt wird sondern die
sind besessen von einer Idee und das
geht getief in die AFD hinein dieses
monoeischen Staates und die benutzen
sozusagen die Empörung um das zu
verkaufen und dass das klar ist dass
jetzt wer die AFD wählt ein spitzenkand
kidat hat der 25 Millionen Leute
ausweisen will der bedroht uns alle eine
Partei die mit diesen Gedanken spielt
ist eine Gefahr für uns alle und das ist
glaube ich jetzt nach dieser Recherche
bekannt und das ist nicht einfachesag
hier man sagt ihr ihr seid Nazis und
erhöht sie damit jetzt liegen die Fakten
auf dem Tisch jetzt ist klar was sie
wollen und das ist jetzt Teil der
politischen Debatte Alexander das stimmt
aber bei den intelligenten Kritikern der
Grenzöffnung 2015 gab es dieses Argument
immer wenn der Staat so wirkt als
kontrollierte er seine Grenzen nicht
mehr also wenn dieses Gefühl des
Kontrollverlustes die Menschen
verunsichert dann kann man darauf etwas
setzen was ganz rechts ist und was es
vorher auch so in der Bundesrepublik auf
jeden Fall nicht in den Dimensionen gab
das war immer Teil der intelligenten
Kritik von Merkels
Politik von daher ist es nicht also es
stimmt was sie sagen aber es ist jetzt
ich finde ja viel interessanter auch in
in diesem Gespräch gerade sie haben ja
den Konflikt gerade exakt beschrieben
also auf der einen Seite macht man die
Leute groß auf der anderen Seite aber
liegen jetzt Fakten auf dem Tisch auf
der einen Seite sagen die einen AFD
Verbotsdebatte um Gottes Willen ich ich
kenne auch die positionition hier in der
Runde so ein bisschen Frau Wagenknecht
sagt es das Dümmste was man machen
könnte Robin Alexander sagt es ähnlich
und dann gibt es andere ich weiß nicht
wo sie da stehen Herr benmann der sagt
Entschuldigung wenn wir doch diese
Instrumente haben wenn wir das ernst
nehmen mit unserer Demokratie da müssen
doch spätestens an dem Punkt zumindest
mal darüber nachdenken und das mal
ernsthaft debattieren ja es gibt ja
dieses toleranzparadox also die Frage
wie geht man damit um es ist ein großes
Dilemma gibt ja dieses toleranzparadox
was macht man mit einer Kraft die das
die Gesellschaft in der wir sind
abschaffen möchte und
zumindestens diese Veranstaltung im
postsam sagte dass sie dahin wollen und
wenn ich so den Herrn K lese in seinem
Buch S Höcker lesen
zweimben 28 schreibt das schreibt da vom
Kranken Volkskörper vom Kranken volkör
und wohltemperierten grausamkeitusamkeit
exakt steht alleigration steht alles
drin und man sollte zumindestens den
Prozess mal offen sten zeigt doch dass
es nichts Neues ist also dass es diese
Leute gibt in der AFD also ich will
jetzt nicht ihre Recherche damit
entwerten aber es zeigt eben dass es
jetzt so neu nicht ist dass sie auch so
ein selner Treffen weil es diese Leute
in der gibt trotzdem ist doch völlig
klar warum wird jetzt über ein Verbot
diskutiert und nicht vor 5 Jahren und
das wissen auch die Wähler der AFD und
das weiß die Gesellschaft es wird jetzt
deswegen darüber diskutiert weil die AFD
so stark ist und das ist eben deswegen
ist diese Verbotsdebatte wirklich ein
Geschenk an die AFD und ein
Armutszeugnis für die Demokratie weil
ich finde wir müssen darüber diskutieren
wieso wird eine Partei trotz höcke trotz
solcher Position so stark weil es ist
nicht so das zeigen alle um fragen wir
haben in der Gesellschaft keinen
Rechtsradikalismus der sich irgendwie
ausgeweitet hat und wir haben schon gar
nicht irgendwie 20% der Bevölkerung die
das gut finden aber wir haben ganz viele
Menschen die sich völlig politisch
heimatlos führen wir haben eine
Regierung die mit einer Überheblichkeit
einer Arroganz einer Planlosigkeit die
Leute im Grunde der AFD in die Arme
treibt und wenn jetzt diese Regierung
die alles dafür getan hat die Menschen
politisch zu verprellen jetzt sagt so
und jetzt sind wir aber sauer weil die
gehen alle zur AFD und jetzt versuchen
wir die zu verbieten dann hat das ist
das kein demokratisch nicht auch so
einfach Frau WAG nicht zu sagen jetzt
gibt es diese diese sie nennen sie mal
die dümmste Regierung Europas und die
und die treiben jetzt die haben ja
objektiv betrachtet eine Menge Themen
und Probleme und Dinge auf dem Tisch die
sie a zum Teil geerbt haben und die zum
anderen Teil von außen an dieses Land
herangetragen worden sind Stichwort
Ukraine Stichwort Putin das heißt die
müssen mit einer ganz neuen Situationen
plötzlich umgehen und das in diesen
aufgewühlten Zeiten ist es nicht auch
auf eine Art irendwi so so seltsam
paternalistisch wenn man sagt da gibt es
diese böse Regierung und dann treibt sie
diese diese dummen Schafe von Wählern
einfach zur zur AFD rüber mir mir ist
das an dem Punkt ehrlich gesagt zu
überheblich also die Leute sind doch
schlau genug und und wissen auch zu gut
Bescheid als dass sie sich von
irgendjemandem irgendwoh hintreiben
ließen die Leute treffen ihre
Entscheidungen schon ganz selbstständig
ganz selbstbewusst und wissen sehr genau
was sie tun